lots of great examples of what you would
call brutalist architecture brutalism
was thought to be futuristic ahead of
its time and actually it was considered
kind of radical especially compared to
the smooth clean sterile quality of
modernism the idea was that they
provided a kind of blank canvas that
could be infilled by people's
experiences over time it was Democratic
social morally right or that was the
idea just look at this concrete
deteriorates and weathers really badly
over time it turns out people don't
actually like hanging out in these
massive raw concrete spaces eventually
these buildings became neglected but the
problem is because these buildings are
just so massive and dense with concrete
apparently it will create a huge amount
of carbon footprint to demolish it so
we're stuck with these cold raw concrete
monsters